Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in chapter number one.
Author by
We had mentioned yesterday the second
narration. It was an narration of
in which the prophet sallallam
said
[Silence]
This narration in which the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam prophesied
about a military, a
an army that will plan to attack the
capital and they will plan to conquer
Mecca.
And the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
says as this military is on its way
towards the Kaa with ill intent when
they find themselves in an open desert
somewhere between where they came from
and the Kaa the house of Allah Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala will cause the earth
to swallow them entirely taking every
last soul amongst them.
And so
has said, "Oh messenger of Allah,
how is it that all of them will be
destroyed when there are amongst them
innocents?"
Innocence in the sense that there are
merchants amongst them, there are people
that join the caravan, they don't know
where it's going, etc. And so the
prophet sallallah.aii Wasallam said,
"All of them will be destroyed
simultaneously
and entirely and Allah will then
resurrect them and judge them based on
their intentions." And the point of the
narration is the power of intention that
even if you physically find yourself
in a bad place, your intention can
remove you. And even if you physically
find yourself away
from a bad thing and in a good place,
your intention can take you to that bad
place.
But to continue on with this narration,
what we didn't mention was what is this
army
and where does it come from and what is
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
speaking about.
The scholars of Islam have placed this
narration
in a timeline just before the emergence
of a
after the of Mahi.
And so Mahi as the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam mentioned
this individual is just a regular man.
He is not a prophet. He's not a
messenger. He will be from the
lineage of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam through Fatima
and he will share a name with the
prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam. So his name will be the same
as the prophet's name. His name will be
[Arabic recitation]
and he will be given bea or pledged
allegiance to at the Ka and that is
where he will begin to build his army
and build his his military and his
plans and so forth to begin his
campaign to restore for justice in the
land as the prophet sallall.aii Wasam
said and so an army will come with the
intention of killing ali defeating his
army destroying the Kaa and the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam mentioned that
Allah will intervene
and cause the earth to swallow this
aggressive army entirely.
Now when we talk about the issues of and
so forth. You know, oftent times,
especially in our time, everybody is
just kind of sitting around waiting for
me to come and solve all of the problems
that the has the Mahi is a magical
guy. He's going to come out. Everybody's
going to pledge allegiance to him and
he's going to fix everyone's problems
for them. Right? That's not at all what
the Mahi was
prophesized by the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam to be. As a matter of
fact,
it would be detrimental for the mi to
emerge in days these because of how
divided the Muslims are because of the
weakened state and the ignorant state
that a lot of the Muslims find
themselves in today. There has to be a
revival of knowledge, a revival of
action, a revival
of inspired generations that come and
reunite the scholars. they describe
the mahi as a head to a body that is
already assembled.
meaning that the Muslims will already be
assembled and one awaiting for al- Mahi
to come and lead their direction.
This is the function of and this falls
just before the emergence of
in the third narration also on the
authority of
anyone who was listening yesterday. What
is
what?
Huh?
Abdah correct
[Silence]
Islam.
The next narration number three,
remember this is all regarding the topic
and the subject of sincerity and
intentions.
She mentions that the messenger or the
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam, the
messenger of Allah, the prophet Muhammad
sallall.aii wasallam said
there is no more hijra after the
conquest of Mecca. And what's me? What's
meant by this? There is no more hij
migration after the conquest of Mecca,
meaning from Mecca,
right? Because initially it was
obligatory upon every able-bodied
Muslim, everyone who was able, man,
woman or child to migrate from Mecca to
Medina or at least to migrate from Mecca
because it became unbearable
and a person was unable to worship Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala there anymore
and so it became a worship an an act of
worship. became almost a right of
passage for every Muslim who is worth
his salt that
when he accepts Islam, he is then to
migrate or she is to migrate if if able.
And so this continued until the conquest
of Mecca. Does anybody know what year
the conquest of Mecca was?
What year after hij conquest of Mecca?
Just take a guess. I won't bite your
head off if you're wrong. Right. The
conquest of Mecca. Was it in the second
year? The third year, the 10th year,
the 10th year. The conquest of Mecca was
in the seventh year after Hij. Some
historians place it in the eighth year
after Hij. But what they are certain of
is that the conquest of Mecca was in the
month of Ramadan for sure. They all
agree on that. They they differ on
whether it was the seventh or eighth
year after hij of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam. When he conquered
Mecca he made this statement
there is no more hij i.e from Mecca to
Medina. However, hij
in the sense of under the circumstances
which made hijra from Mecca obligatory
in the first place, this will continue
until the day of judgment. Hijra will
always exist, migrating from a land
where you are unable to worship Allah to
a place where you are able to worship
Allah will continue on until the day of
judgment until the day until the day the
sun rises from the west. but migration
from Mecca away from it. This has ended
with the conquest of Mecca. And this is
interesting because it's also a prophecy
that Mecca will never again fall
entirely into the hands of the
disbelievers. It never again will fall
disbelievers.
It is going to be for the Muslims until
the end of time until the emergence of a
and there is no more Muslims remaining
on the earth then and only then. The
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam said
yet what remains for the people of Mecca
is jihad to join the ranks of the mujah
and intention. intention meaning if you
are unable to join those ranks for
whatever reason the intention of giving
victory to the Muslims wherever they may
be he said
he's speaking now to the Muslims of
Mecca he said and if you are called upon
to join the ranks of the Muslim armies
then you are to oblige you are to answer
that call immediately this narration was
collected by both bkari and Muslim. That
is enough for this morning. We'll
continue this tomorrow inshallah. We ask
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala to teach us
that which will benefit us and to
benefit us from that which he teaches
us.
[Arabic recitation]